bienvenue à paroles autochtone si c'est
melissa maulin dupuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question qui ont été énormément
à coeur de la part d'anne marie elle me
demande peux-tu expliquer la crise qui
secoue présentement cannes à s'attaquer
aux canaries pour pouvoir même commencé
à l'expliquer je vais remonter en 1990
parce qu'on parle d'un événement
historique au québec c'est à dire la
crise d'oka ce que les militants
autochtones préfère rappeler la
résistance de oca parce que c'est un
moment où justement la communauté de
kahnawake a défendu les droits pour un
territoire qu'elle considère non cd
c'est à dire la pinède d'oka qui devait
être transformé en terrain de golf
on sait que pendant l'été de 1990 il ya
eu une présence militaire sur ce terrain
là pour pouvoir contrer justement les
réclamations des mots rock pékin
s'attaquait presque 30 ans plus tard on
revient même enjeu même pinède même
nation encore à cannes à stocker un
nouveau maire cependant est présentement
on vit un moment politique qui est très
mélangeant parce que beaucoup de ces
angelots ne sont pas connues
premièrement le transfert de terrain qui
doit se faire donner maintenant à cannes
à stocker vient d'un développeur qui a
des terrains un peu partout autour de
quoi il veut redonner la pinède à la
communauté certains membres de la
communauté sont très contents de
recevoir le terrain dit c'est une des
premières avancées qui a enfin par
rapport aux réclamations qu'on a sur la
pinède
mais aussi une partie de la communauté
qui sont pas d'accord parce que
justement ces terrains n'ont jamais été
cédés en recevant les terrains du
promoteur ce serait comme dire
finalement il appartenait à cette
personne et il nous les donne alors que
pour une question de réclamer de futurs
et de présent droits ancestraux ses
terres elles doivent être reconnus comme
toujours avoir été jamais céder donc une
question importante par rapport à ce
qu'on reçoit un cheval de troie
présentement en ce faisant donné un
terrain et que présentement la cour
suprême canadienne après votre belle à
vous recevez des terrains des promoteurs
donc vous reconnaissez que c'est d'être
ans
de terrain plus traditionnelles non
autochtone que liées aux droits
ancestraux autochtone ça c'est le
premier angle qu'on peut voir et là
malheureusement c'est perdu un peu dans
le message parce qu'il ya eu des propos
très malheureux et très disgracieux de
l'apport du maire qui ont mis de
l'essence dans le feu comme on dit et ce
qu'on voit beaucoup présenté dans les
médias aussi c'est qu'il ya des
interactions entre certains journalistes
et des membres de la communauté de
kahnawake et c'est deuxième angle là
aussi un peu perdu dans la compréhension
de la population parce que faut pas
oublier qu'en 1990 les membres la
communauté étaient présents et ont subi
quand même une couverture médiatique qui
était très dommageable pour la
communauté et qui encore aujourd'hui à
des impacts donc devoir d'aimer dieu
arriver et de se demander est-ce qu'ils
vont encore nous couvrir de la même
manière qu'en 1990 parce qu'ils arrivent
seulement quand il ya une crise c'est de
ne pas douter de voir des réactions très
vives la part des membres la communauté
par chance aujourd'hui il ya eu un
travail de transformation des médias et
aussi on peut compter sur des médias
autochtones comme à ptn qui a paru en
1992 après la crise d'octobre où le
eastern door qui est un journal de
kahnawake
alors pour pouvoir faire une bonne tête
autour de ça n'hésitez pas à aller voir
le documentaire d'alanis obomsawin qui
est d'ailleurs disponible gratuitement
sur le site de louer 9 270 ans de
résistance je pense que chaque québécois
devraient voir ce documentaire là une
fois dans sa vie
et surtout n'hésitez pas à parler à des
gens qui ont été présents pendant la
crise merci beaucoup en arrêt pour ta
question
en espérant avoir pu répondre de manière
éclairée et n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
des questions est ce parce autochtone je
souhaite une belle semaine